While the rest of Mexico celebrated the victory of Andrés Manuel López Obrador,
this small town went about its business.
That's because elections are banned here.
Cherán sits in the northwest portion of Michoacán.
The state is overrun by violent crime and political corruption.
But not here.
Cherán's 20,000 residents solved those problems by
kicking out politicians, cops and its mayor.
Strict rules forbid political parties and campaigning within the town limits.
Even motorists entering Cherán have to remove party bumper stickers.
Cherán also hasn't had a murder, kidnapping or disappearance in seven years.
Minor offenses like theft, drunk driving and disorderly conduct
are dealt with by imposing community service.
One way the town curtailed crime was limiting access.
Three entry checkpoints are staffed by guards with assault rifles and body armor.
They're part of a homegrown patrol system in charge of protecting the town.
That includes Andrés Fabián.
The town's transformation began in 2011,
after a group of women decided to drive away illegal loggers.
Witnesses rang the town bells to alert the community,
and this set off an uprising that became known as the chiming.
Up until this point, the town had been overrun by the loggers,
who harassed and threatened residents.
Today, Cherán is governed by its residents, with strict rules and guidelines
based on their indigenous Purépecha roots.
Each block in Cherán discusses their issues at a community bonfire.
Then they elect K’eris, or representatives like Enerino Santaclara,
to bring these issues to the general assembly.
The community has also been slowly restoring the forest
and nursing tree seedlings in a community garden.
Cherán has become an example for other communities across Mexico.
In 2018, 32 towns boycotted the presidential elections.
Others are now looking to replicate its success against crime and corruption.